[Music]
the deal has been years in the making
but the trade dispute between China and
the United States has created a fresh
urgency for both superpowers to look for
new partners Argentina is the world's
biggest producer of soybean meal with
about 43 percent of the market much of
it will now be used to feed China's
estimated 400 million pigs the signing
of this protocol establishes a solid and
legal basis so the convergence of these
two huge markets and delight from
Argentina the deal of boost to an
economy in recession Sasori
Toriko this is an historic achievement
as we have worked hard for for over 20
years we have wanted to open up this
market and we know it will be highly
valued by the Argentine soy sector
Argentina already exports soya beans and
all to China and its agricultural sector
is pushing for more Argentina has to try
to sell products of higher value that's
the challenge that Argentina has in
relation to China to try to improve and
deepen the sale of these products which
it is doing
China to meet its food and energy needs
has invested heavily in Latin America's
infrastructure roads railways and ports
the key is to have something that both
China in the United States wants that
they used to get from one another but no
longer due because of their trade
dispute but then not risk offending
either superpower politically because
things change and nobody wants to put
future trade deals in jeopardy however
there are still administrative hurdles
to overcome and some urge caution over
getting too excited Argentina is an
important food producer but it doesn't
have stock and it doesn't have
investments because as everyone knows
the economic situation here is delicate
and to try to expand export capacity at
the moment is impossible there's no
credit and we can't expand export
capacity then there's the United States
to worry about Argentina recently
resolved a four ten-year trade to speak
with the US over meat exports it's a
major trading partner with substantial
political influence in what it sees as
its backyard the US State Department has
made various moves to warn countries in
Latin America to beware of increasing
its trade with China many also warn that
the current trade dispute is merely a
skirmish and a much bigger war to come
over technology and intellectual
property rights while their satisfaction
here over the deal just done there's
still uncertainty over the next moves to
come from Beijing and Washington swine
they're out to zerah when Osiris